denmark is not a very big place the
danish realm
is absolutely massive and this is
exclusively down to the inclusion of
greenland
and given its size its important
position and its distance from the
nation of denmark this raises a question
how did it come to be in the possession
of the danes and how did they keep it
so by the 10th century the danes and
norse vikings had been sailing all over
europe doing what they do best
and part of that were settling lands
like the pharaoh islands in iceland
some norsemen opted to go west and came
across greenland where they too
settled and it wasn't long until one of
these settlers late for eriksen
travelled from greenland to north
america becoming the first european to
ever do so
greenland was already poorly populated
and as such was mostly ignored by the
norwegian monarchy although it was a
formal part of the kingdom
and this was mostly down to a lack of
communication since a round trip from
greenland to trondheim took many months
by the 15th century mostly due to the
plague the norwegians were gone and in
their absence the portuguese laid claim
to the land
that said they never did anything there
and so everyone just ignored this claim
at the turn of the 16th century empire
was very fashionable and not wanting to
be left out the kingdom of denmark
norway ruled by one man with two
different titles sought to colonize
greenland again
and in the 18th century greenland joined
iceland and the pharaoh islands as a
formal part of the kingdom of norway
seems pretty simple who it would belong
to but in came napoleon to complicate
things
as always now denmark made one silly
decision during napoleon's tenure which
was to be his ally
this led to two outcomes first was that
britain shelled copenhagen
finally teaching the danes how it feels
to have a bunch of angry ships turn up
off your shore and set things on fire
the second outcome was that the kingdom
of denmark norway lost norway to sweden
in the treaty of keele
as part of this treaty it was stated
that whilst denmark would lose norway it
would retain the faro islands iceland
and greenland which were then
increasingly settled by the danish in
the following century
in 1867 denmark was approached by the
united states with a cash offer to buy
greenland and iceland i mean because if
you can buy alaska why not greenland the
danish said no
norway would go on to gain its
independence in 1905 and immediately
disputed denmark's ownership of
greenland
nothing much was done though until 1931
when the norwegians led by the explorer
helga ingstad sailed to greenland and
settled this region they did this
because as far as they were concerned
the danish were only given the occupied
area of greenland in the treaty of keel
and not all of it
this dispute went to international
arbitration and in the end it was
decided that norway needed to calm down
and leave
which they did in 1933 so after this
denmark's ownership of the island was
fairly secure
the exception was in world war ii and
after the fall of denmark greenland was
occupied by the united states for the
rest of the war
when peace was restored in europe
president truman offered the danish a
pretty large sum of money in return for
greenland
this was because its geographic position
was valuable in controlling the north
atlantic
specifically preventing the ussr from
doing anything there
again denmark said no and afterwards
greenland was formally incorporated into
the danish realm gaining more autonomy
over the following decades
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker the
pastry section marvin castle rob
waterhouse moe
aaron the white james castaneda danny
maloney jordan longley marcus arsenault
gustav swan jerry lambton john bailey
spinning three plates
rasheed ali cooling castleman david
silverman izzy
coppertone maggie paxkowski winston k
wood lexi schwinn spencer lightfoot
robert wedsil fortunate calf anthony
beckett and sky chappelle